for Glen Villa new scouting animal
behavior in the Brooks Range is key to
harvesting meat and protein for survival
in the fall doll sheep hunting season
will be open and locating them now as a
priority I'm gonna head up into the
mountains this morning spend a few days
walking around finding a promising area
to hunt a couple of months from now
hunting sheep is the most physically
demanding hunting I do I have to walk
further and more difficult terrain and
spend more time seeking out sheep than
any other animal I hunt sheep like to
stay up high where there rocks they can
escape to when the Predators are around
that's how they get away from wolves
that's how they get away from me I'm
gonna head up this Ridge see what I can
find up there I'm getting up above
treeline now I gotta start thinking
about being quiet you know start
thinking about direction of the wind how
it's carrying my scent and I gotta start
using terrain to conceal myself because
the sheep are very cautious animals
this is a sheep trail right here
they're sheep scat there's a beautiful
sheep track right there this is a path
the Sheep walk regularly on this
mountain scouting for sheep it's the
same thing as hunting them the only
difference is I'm not gonna shoot it
when I get there but I'm trying to stalk
as close as I can to any sheep and any
time I'm out I'm gaining experience
these are all sheep rather against where
sheep has laid scat they're here
this is more of a summer scat when
they're eating more succulent vegetation
in the winter it'll look more like this
in wintertime I'm seeing lots of sheep
sign on this mountain so I'm hopeful I
might find some sheep up here thanks for
looking good